mikati es representa a esa élite
política a la clase gobernante que ha
estado en el poder durante los últimos
40 años y es por eso que ha dejado su
reelección un gusto amargo y también
dulce para una parte de la población
mikati significa la estabilidad ya fue
primer ministro en 2005 y en 2011 y fue
reelegido el verano pasado en septiembre
y consiguió desbloquear una crisis
política de dos años al formar gobierno
ya que durante los dos últimos años no
se consiguió formar un gobierno de
líbano pero por otra parte para los
votantes que votaron por el cambio en
las elecciones del 15 de mayo mikati
representa a ese no cambio que todas las
cosas van a seguir igual a nivel
internacional mikati su nombre bien
conocido es un exitoso hombre de
negocios que tiene negocios por medio
mundo y una fortuna de 2700 millones de
dólares y es por eso que también
representa ese hombre fuerte que puede
sacar al líbano del agujero en el que se
encuentra la profunda crisis económica
que es la mayor que ha tenido en la
historia del país y justamente qué
expectativas tiene el líbano con el
nuevo gobierno para salir de la crisis
de la que estamos hablando y que golpea
el país desde 2019
bueno el líbano está en una espiral sin
salida el líbano necesita para poder ser
rescatado económicamente precisamente en
la formación de un gobierno un gobierno
fuerte y sobre todo que lleve a cabo
unas reformas económicas creíbles para
poder recuperar la confianza de la
comunidad internacional
mikati precisamente comenzó a hacer unas
negociaciones con el fondo monetario
internacional en el mes de abril por lo
que se piensa que sí mikati sigue con
esas negociaciones con esas
conversaciones finalmente el fmi podrá
dar a líbano 3 mil millones siempre y
cuando se lleven a cabo esas reformas
económicas también hay congelados 11
millones de dólares desde parís y
también se exige al líbano que se llevan
a cabo reformas económicas para que se
reduzca la deuda externa